what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python tutorial video in this
video what we're talking about is how to
use pip to install any module you want
even if it's not included in the simple
like pi PI package index so first I'm
going to show you how you would install
something if it is in the Python package
index and if it's not I'll show you how
to install that as well so for things
like 64-bit versions of your favorite
modules like numpy you have to get them
elsewhere and then a lot of custom
modules may not be hosted up on Python
package index so anyway to start anyone
who's using a new her version of say
Python 3 is going to have pip installed
it just came with your installation so
to use it what you're going to do is go
to your Start bar and if you don't have
it I have it right here but if you don't
have it just type in CMD and that will
bring up this program you can click on
that and this is your command prompt
obviously if you're on Linux you can
open up bash and you can open up a shell
if you're on you know Mac OS and all
that so basically get to your bash shell
command prompt whatever you want to call
it and you're ready to use pip now a lot
of people especially if you just have a
single installation of Python you should
be able to get away which is typing pip
install and then the module of choice so
say you want to matplotlib you could do
this now this is not gonna work for me
well I'll hit enter but it's going to
give me a big fat err sure enough and
the reason for this is um because of my
I'm using 64-bit Python but anyway that
would normally work if you're on 32-bit
but I will be talking about you folks
who are on 64-bit so you can do that now
the other thing you'll notice is this
try to install for python 2 7 while i'm
using python 3 for primarily or maybe
you're using 3-4 but you wanted pip
install to 7 or your you've got you like
pip is referencing python to 7 but you
want to use python 3 so what do you do
well if you want to reference the
specific version you would give the full
path to pythons pip so c colon slash
python 34 with a cap
P slash scripts with a capital S and if
it's plural and then pip and then you
could say install matplotlib
now again at least this one it's happy
mostly because it's up it's up to date
so if there was no problem but I'll show
you how I can at least make mine angry
and you can see that you can hit the up
arrow and instead of instable with
install you can add another parameter
because I already have matplotlib but
say you want to upgrade it well you can
see right here you just add the argument
of upgrade so pip install - - upgrade
now again this is going to make my
computer mad but it probably won't make
yours mad because well unless you have
64-bit num pipes that memorize what's
going to throw this one for a loop but
anyway up until this point yes it works
and so this you see this common error if
you're using 64-bit Python this is very
familiar to you and it might be familiar
to you even if you're not using 64-bit
but this is a very common problem and
basically you have to update your
version of Visual Basic if you're
getting this error there might be
several reasons why you either don't
want to or you can't update Visual Basic
or you can't figure it out or whatever
I'm not going to really get into that
but if you're getting this error that's
kind of your problem is you're trying to
install something that either isn't
supported or you don't have the proper C
compiler and so on so now how do we
handle that problem as well as how do we
handle getting a package that isn't say
on Python package index so all the
modules that are supported by pip like
as in just typing pip out and getting
that module are on here pi PI python.org
and this is the Python package index now
if just anybody makes a package they
can't necessarily upload it or get it on
Python package index without at least a
little bit of a weight so there might be
packages that just aren't here there
might also be because this is basically
where all the official sources of
packages are going to be but some of the
official sources of package ie numpy are
just simply not available in 64-bit so
we have to get around that now my
website of choice in the past
get around this looks like I've
misplaced it let me open that up real
quick
has been this unofficial binary source
and I liked it because I had dot exe
files super simple but now he's moving
mostly two-wheel files which is kind of
moving along with the times a lot of
people are moving the wheel pip now
installs wheel files so what the heck is
a wheel file so for example let's say we
we want num Pike's that was throwing me
for a loop so I just do a ctrl F to find
numpy and here is numpy click on that
and that takes you to numpy down here
now which one do I need well let's read
what this says it has basically numpy MK
l that's part of numpy right that's this
is it numpy - MK l then you have CP 34
CP stands for cpython which is the
default version of python not to be
confused with scythe on so see python
version 3.4 none here don't worry about
that and then I'm on Windows and E 64
because I'm on 64-bit if you're on
32-bit you could get this but pip
install numpy should work for you but
again there might be some packages that
are not available using just straight
pip and then just a package name that
doesn't exist on your computer so if
that if pip install fails you can come
here or download the wheel file from
whoever the producer of your module or
packages so here I'm going to download a
numpy I've already actually got it
downloaded but you just need to click it
and here it would come now the only
problem that you might have at least
with this website like some websites you
might be able to especially if it's on
github you can just double you get and
then you could install it really simply
this one I'm not really sure how to W
get it because I think I'm pretty sure
like if I just append this up here I'm
pretty sure yeah like that won't
download it so I don't know what the
link is and if you like right click and
say copy link address it's just it's
empty it's just JavaScript so anyway not
too sure how to get the specific link
there but obviously that's possible on
most websites or many websites so here's
the wheel file and if we go
to computer and I click on downloads
here it is ok so now what do you do once
you have the wheel file well what you
can do is at least on Windows you can
hold the left shift right click and you
can open the command window there it
might be a shortcut like that on Linux
and Mac OS and all that I don't know it
if you do know it feel free to post it
in the description let people know but
anyways so here we are I'm in this
downloads and then now I can type the
same thing as I did before so I would
say C colon slash Python 34 scripts pit
install and then I you can either change
the name of this but you should be able
to just do and you tab and that should
just finish out the whole file for you
hit enter and then now this is going to
download and install numpy for me and
that's it simple as that with wheel
files now um that's basically it with
pip install if you're having any
problems feel free to leave a comment
below but that should be it I know that
it's sometimes a pain whenever like you
know the download and installation
methodologies change but this is
definitely better than before so for a
while it was set up to up high or pip or
like you could use setup tools which
kind of worked in with a set up to up
high files on a huge mess and then it
became the case that pretty much
everyone had set up that pie so that was
the method IO is used and then now it's
getting a little easier with a pip
installs so I think that is the future
that's kind of the way that everyone's
going so hopefully it works out for you
so again if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all the sports
subscriptions until next time